but this is going to teach you how to
refute objections how to interpret the
Bible what the Bible teaches about your
faith why you should believe what you
believe and how to turn it against the
Muslims
okay let's see the passages that
cited they quote 1 John 3:20 for if our
God condemns us God is greater than our
heart and knows all things see God knows
all things 1 John
3:20 Luke 2:52 and Jesus increased in
wisdom and stature and in favor with God
and man Luke 252 chap 2:52 Jesus
increased in wisdom and stature and in
favor with God and man so here's the
statement we know that God does not
increase in wisdom God is all wise so
first objection Luke 2:52 says Jesus
increased in wisdom and stature and
between God and man and yet first John
3:20 teaches that God knows everything
you understand the objection
okay here's how you interpret these
objections
anytime your opponent cites a book he
now gives you the authority to use that
book or that author to refute them what
do I mean notice what he quoted 1 John
3:20 the moment he quotes any of the
writings of John he pretty much has
given you the green lie he's not giving
you the auth authorization authorization
to use John to destroy his argument say
I'm teaching you I'm trusting the Holy
Spirit to fill me with wisdom to glorify
Christ and sharpen me to sharpen you as
we yield to the Holy Spirit please Holy
Spirit perfect us for the glory of
Christ and give me the health i e to
glorify Christ so notice number
one the moment he quotes a writer or an
author it's over for him wait you just
quot it 1 John 3 vers
20 good so now when I quote John to
refute you and embarrass you you can
object to John by quoting him you
endorse him and you authorize me to use
him to refute
you are you with me
there you understand what I'm doing
right now before I move on by the grace
of God's spirit as we yield to the
spirit the spirit will show us how
irrefutable our fa faith is how solid
the Bible Bible is because the Bible is
the voice of God and it's the
impenetrable rock that cannot be
destroyed but destroys and crushes
everything that opposes it New King
James Version John 16
25-31 John 16
25-31 now let's learn our faith
something that we all can agree and
enjoy and be blessed and edified read
with me these things I have spoken to
you in figurative language but the time
is coming when I will no longer speak to
you in figurative language see I'm not
going to speak figuratively but I will
tell you plainly about the
father and that day you will ask in in
my name and I do not say to you that I
shall pray the father for you for the
father himself loves you because you
have loved me and have believed that I
came forth from God okay now pay
attention to 28
I came forth from the father and have
come into the world again I leave the
world and go to the father his disciples
said to him see now you're speaking
plainly plainly not figuratively it's no
longer Parables you're speaking plain
clear
language and because you're speaking
plainly and you're using no figure of
speech now we are sure that you know all
things bam before his death and
Resurrection while on Earth Jesus Christ
is set to know all things now we are
sure that you know all things and have
no need that anyone should question you
by this we believe that you came forth
from God Jesus answered them do you now
believe so notice when Jesus starts
starts speaking plainly not Parables
anymore the disciples say ah now we
understand you now we know you came from
the father Out of Heaven so you existed
in heaven before you came to the Earth
and now we realize you know all things
and do not need to be questioned in
order to see whether you know what
you're talking
about and Jesus says oh you finally
believe
huh it took a while but you finally
believe now let me explain what it means
you need no want to question you you
either ask questions because you want to
learn or you ask questions to test if
someone knows what they're talking about
oh yeah you think you're an expert on
the subject well how do you answer this
when he answerers like wow man you
really know your stuff no need to ask
you anymore that's what they're
saying yes this is before his death and
Resurrection what's there to be confused
about in John 16 it's right
there right so number one did Jesus know
all things before he died while he was
on Earth yes did Jesus continue to know
all things after he rose again yes
because in John
21:17 three weeks after his
resurrection John 21:17 but we're going
to read John 21: 15-1
17 three weeks after his resurrection he
appears to the disciples again John 21:1
15-17
so when they had eaten breakfast Jesus
said to Simon Peter Simon son of Jonah
do you love me more than these meaning
the fish do you love me more than the
fish and your trade because he's a
fisherman they were out fishing that
that morning what do Simon say yes
Lord he said to him yes Lord you know
that I love you he said to him feed my
Lambs he said to him again a second time
Simon son of Jonah
do you love me he said to him yes Lord
you know that I love you he said to him
tend my sheep he said to him the third
time Simon son of Jonah do you love me
Peter was grieved because he said to him
the third time do you love me and he
said to him Lord you know all things you
know that I love you Jesus said to him
feed my sheep in other words when
Peter's saying why are you even
bothering asking me we already know that
you know all things you know all Hearts
you know what's in our heart you know if
we love you or not so why are you asking
you know all things so wait before his
death he knows all things after his
death he knows all things so Jesus
wasn't asking because he didn't know he
was asking for a different
reason making
sense and every one of you know why he's
asking here is the compassionate
merciful loving heart of of Jesus Peter
denied him three times so what did Jesus
do he didn't come to Peter and say shame
on you here I am alive in the flesh what
do you got to say for yourself you
denied me three
times what should I do to you now no
that's not Jesus you know what Jesus is
instead of Peter
saying Jesus Son of God do you still
love me after betraying you notice the
humbleness of Our Lord Simon son of
Jonah do you love
me notice what the Lord is saying he's
not he's it's not Peter asking him Lord
do you still love me after I betrayed
you how could you still love me I'm no
no no no that's not the art of Christ
it's the
opposite Jesus loves you to the end and
forever if Jesus is in love with you and
you are his he loves you
forever so he tells Simon Simon do you
love me yes Lord you know I love you
feed my sheep Simon do you love me yes
Lord you know I love you feed my land
Simon do you love me the reason why he
asked him three times is to make him
confess and undo all the times he denied
him for every time you denied me I will
lovingly gently restore
you and use you again I don't know this
man Simon do you love me yes I do I
swear I don't know this man Simon do you
love me yes I do I'm telling you I don't
know this man Simon do you love me yes
Lord you know I love you He restored him
but then he says something
else he says something
else now that you say you love me you're
going to have to show me your love Simon
here's what I expect from you here's
what I demand of you if you love me if
you love
me then you're going to love my church
feed my church care for my church and
watch over my church because those who
love me will keep my word those who love
me Father please bless the connection in
Jesus name y please Lord I hate when it
buffers not connected to the router
modem those who love me will keep my
word those who love me will obey my
command so Simon you've now confessed
Your Love Show Me Your Love In Action
and no better way of showing me that you
love me but by loving my church caring
for my church watching over my church
teaching my church and protecting my
church from wolves snakes and
scorpions
okay everyone with me Focus don't be
distracted focus and don't be distracted
so the same John who wrote 1 John 3:20
the same John who wrote 1 John 3: 20
learn this
principle learn this
principle the
moment
someone quotes an author to refute your
faith that's it you've got him
understand this principle guys please so
number one did we establish from the
same John who wrote first John that in
the Gospel of John Jesus knows
everything while he was on Earth Earth
before his death and even after his
resurrection did we establish that in
John 16
25-31 and John
21:17 Jesus before his resurrection
after his resurrection knows all things
and it's not hyperbole how do we know
it's not hyperbole because in John 16:
25-31 it said I'm speaking plainly not
figuratively plain language and the
disciples say ah now that you're
speaking plain language not figuratively
now we get it you know everything and
you came from the father from Heaven
into the Earth not figuratively not
hyperbolic hyperbolically but literally
not hyperbolically literally you know
everything that's why we don't need to
question and test you anymore and you
did come from the father from Heaven
into the world right so that was John
but wait he quoted Luke as well we're
going to have a field day with this
objection he quoted Luke as well and in
so doing you're going to learn your
faith learn how to interpret the Bible
how not to interpret it be strengthened
in your faith that you have the true God
and Christ is God In the Flesh the Bible
is his word and turn it against these
antitrinitarians okay now he went to
Luke
2:52 H you mean the same Luke that says
the following in Luke
10:22 remember once he quotes an author
he stuck with that author let's go to
Luke
10:22 he quoted Luke 25 2 let's go to
Luke 10:22 Now read with me folks guys
please help me to help you learn grow
with me by the power of the holy spirit
so we can know our faith be assured of
our faith love our faith love the god of
our faith and his word for the glory of
Jesus Luke
1022 all things have been delivered to
me by my father all things have been
delivered to me by my father no one
knows who the son is except the father
and who the father is except the Son and
the one to whom the son Wills to reveal
him talk about meat even liberal
critical critical Scholars liberal
critical Scholars say this is an
astonishing assertion that sounds like
the Gospel of John right they call it
yan yan yan yan yan Johan
Johan say that five times fast yanin or
Johan or johannan or Johan Thunderbolt
yep Thunderbolt okay okay why is this
astonishing folks number one notice what
our Lord is saying about the father no
one knows the father why why doesn't
anyone know the father because the
father is incomprehensible that's what
they call it like a ThunderBolt from
John's gospel found and Matthew and Luke
yep
AAP no no one knows the father why
because the father is incomprehensible
and omniscient it is not possible for a
creature to know the
father infinitely and comprehensively
that's why it says no one knows the
father because the father is beyond
comprehension but he says something
astonishing except the son but notice
the first part of it pay attention to
the first part of it it gets even better
no one knows who the son is except the
father likewise no one knows who the
father is except the son wait wait wait
okay Lord I understand no one knows who
the father is because he's an infinite
mind he's he's omniscient he's
incomprehensible by Nature so creature
cannot know God comprehensively and
infinitely but you said in the same way
no one knows the son are you claiming to
be incomprehensible and omniscient like
the father is that's number one number
two you then say though no one knows the
father you know him and no one knows you
except the father so are you saying that
because you're
incomprehensible only the father can
know you truly and completely and
exhaustively because it requires an
omniscient mind to know you implication
you two are beyond comprehension but
then you say you know the Father the
same way the father father knows you but
Lord hold on the father knows you inside
and out knows you completely
comprehensively knows every thought of
yours are you saying you know the Father
the same way he knows you you know the
father to the same extent that the
father knows you so that the father
who's
incomprehensible omniscient but you know
him inside and out and only the father
can know you truly because like the
father you too are incomprehensible
omniscient that's what you're implying
in this
saying did you get
it did you get
it before I move on notice how he States
it no one knows who the son is except
the father why why only the father can
know
you and no one knows who the father is
except the son how is it you can know
the father to the same extent the father
knows you and we understand why no one
can know the father because he's Beyond
Comprehension so are you saying likewise
no one can you can know you because you
too are Beyond Comprehension which is
why only God the Father Can know you
because he has an omniscient mind to
know that which is incomprehensible and
Beyond the ability of any creature to
know but then you know the father to the
same extent that he knows you is that
making sense is it sinking in
exactly Alex Luke
10:22 goes hand in hand perfectly with
proverbs 30 verse3 and 4 proverbs 30
verse 3 and 4 the holy ones that are
Beyond A's ability to fully completely
know and comprehend